another Senate race that's neck-and-neck
is in Missouri Democratic Senator Claire
McCaskill is running for a third term
against state attorney general Josh
Hawley the show-me-state has leaned
Republican in recent elections President
Trump wanted by nearly 19 points in 2016
Dean Reynolds is in Springfield Missouri
Dean good morning good morning well
Missouri Attorney General Josh Holley
will be here at campaign headquarters
greeting volunteers in a couple of hours
it'll be the first of five stops for
Hawley across the state today including
one tonight in Cape Girardeau hosted by
one of his staunchest supporters the
President of the United States mr. Trump
has called Hawley a star and has derided
Pauli's Democratic opponent Senator
Claire McCaskill as a captive of the far
left now McCaskill has tried to insulate
herself from such attacks by claiming
that her Senate record is centrist and
that she is not one of those crazy
Democrats as she puts it McCaskill who
is 65 years old has outraised Holly four
to one and yet the race here is
basically a dead heat she is one of ten
Senate Democrats running for re-election
in state's won by mr. Trump back in 2016
and Republicans here in Missouri believe
this race provides one of their best
shots at victory Nora that's right they
call those ten the Trump ten Democrats
running in those states Dean thank you
so much we'll be watching closely